first of all I want to ask to show me
I've been watching his workout videos
you you've been out there working and
getting everything together getting that
game together - he's so good in
basketball he's such a good student and
just a good person he makes me very
proud I want to ask you this because
ever the Internet has been burning up
about you and the fantastic how
fantastic you've looked what what is
going on what's all new diet working out
more just just focusing more on just
myself and summertime all women like to
turn it up in the summer and work out
eat healthy I just been following a good
plan yeah you have found a fantastic
plan and the pictures have been amazing
I mean you've gone viral
all right power you are going to power
is going to be amazing this season tell
me about power power is amazing it
premieres tonight it's such an
incredible night my birthday's today so
today's like an incredible day across
the board happy birthday - thank you so
much all right here's what I want to
know are you gonna be a basketball
player and already who has the better
jump shot you are your daddy really I
saw that jumper the other day on
Instagram it looked good it looked good
how are you doing and what's next for
you so I'm doing great Nexus powers
premiering tonight it's gonna be an
amazing season a roller coaster ride I
just wrapped an incredible movie with
Whoopi Goldberg and set to Thompson I'm
working I'm writing books I got a
clothing line dropping in Lord and
Taylor this summer it's gonna be good
summer well we see the family back
together we're always a family no matter
what what we see in back cuz uh we're a
family no matter what okay
people are like are you crazy right now
you have a cement
you